Morin Bushnell's new man makes his  social media debut yes you don't know  now you know 27 year old reality star  has gone public with her budding romance  with boyfriend  Devin Anton's Lauren shared this sweet  snap holding Devin's hand while the two  vacations in Hawaii writing okay cutie  with a heart eyes emoji a source  confirmed to et in July Lauren was  dating the 28 year old real estate agent  and the relationship quote happened very  quickly the source added Lauren is happy  and having a great time the new romance  comes just two months after The Bachelor  winner called it quits with fiance and  former bachelor Ben Higgins but do  Lauren and Ben keep in touch ét recently  got that answer from Lauren's besties  and former bachelor contestant Amanda  Stanton I don't think they really talked  but they're on the turn